so let's talk a bit more about that
people spoke March in London yesterday
because organizers said that more than
700,000 people turned out and they're
hoping to put pressure on the government
to put any brexit deal to a national
vote one of the organizers was Alastair
Campbell Tony Blair's former director of
communication he joins us now in the
studio thank you for being with us oh
yeah 700,000 people extraordinary
turnout do you think it'll make any
difference well I hope so and I think
one of the reasons why there was such a
big turnout far bigger than to be frank
we'd anticipated I think is because
people feel that the brexit process
contrary to what the Minister has just
said is not going well that nobody
actually voted for the brexit that is
now on offer people are beginning to see
there's no deal available that as good
as what we have and I think the other
thing is that people sense this vacuum
in leadership and therefore that was
people were coming together I know the
bright stream is as I call them like to
say this is the establishment that was
not the establishment there were people
there from literally every part of the
country who were just not happy with the
way this is going they're not going to
unite around this vision of breaks it I
don't think any won't disagree that
there are people who are really
passionately unhappy with braixen but at
the same time millions of people voted
for braixen
many of them felt ignored by politicians
before they're gonna be listening to you
saying we're just being ignored again I
mean who did you think voted in the last
people's fate if it wasn't people yeah
there were people of the 17 point 4
million who were on that March yesterday
this was not just people who voted
remained there were people who voted
leave there also probably people who
voted to remain he just wish we'd get on
with it
listen the whole country is kind of
saying can't we just talk about
something else can't we get this done
with but when people keep saying I heard
Nigel fries last night saying the
country just wants to get on with it
what is it the it's a lot of people want
to get on with breakfast yes but the it
has to become as you've just heard from
from the brexit Minister it has to
become a treaty it has to become words
and legislation which Parliament agrees
to and there is no it
I don't believe isn't it that she's
going to be able to get through
Parliament what happens then it may
actually be that that is the moment amid
the chaos that might follow that if you
can't get a majority in parliament for
it
that that's when it goes to people's
vote I want to see you just read the
front pages I can remember Alan Clark
former Tory Minister fellow diarist I
can remember him phoning me up once I
think it was between the first and
second of Tony Blair's election wins and
he said we have absolutely had it and I
said why do you say that
he said we now hate each other more than
we hate you that's happening to the Tory
party now and I just think is so chaotic
they are so divided they are so
incompetent the idea of trusting them to
negotiate the most serious set of
decisions that this country's faced in
in our lifetime I think is absurd you
brought up your Diaries there so let's
have a look at what you wrote in your
diary at the time when around a million
people marched on Iraq
you wrote this I bumped into no end of
people coming back from the March Sicard
underarms faces full of
self-righteousness so you now the self
righteous ones well I'm certainly
somebody who believes passionately what
it is that I'm fighting for as people
did then and I do I understand why
people bring up the Iraq March because
it was the biggest it was bigger than
yesterday and it was ignored by the
government the term Tony Blair was the
prime minister and ultimately we elect
prime ministers and cabinets to take
very very difficult decisions we're in
this mess because David Cameron I think
abdicate abdicated the responsibility of
leadership and put out a referendum I
think this referendum is very very
different both to Iraq and to the first
referendum because Gary Lineker was one
of the he was doing much of the day so
he spoke from by video but he made the
point that it's very very rare in life
that you actually do have the benefit of
some hindsight we've had the vote two
and a half years on half a parliament
nobody voted for this mess nobody voted
for this dog but how do you know you
really can you name any one that you're
really close to you voted to leave the
EU and I mean close not just all you
know a little bit yeah I've got friends
I've got very close friends we virgins
what do they think of you now Oh
overturn their decision thinking they
didn't quite understand it last time no
I think I think they understand that
democracy is a process it's a debate you
carry on arguing defuse me I'm a friend
of mine yeah I've gotten lots of friends
in Burnley and Bernard Burnley voted
leave by a very considerable majority
but actually two of the guys who were
under one of the videos yesterday they
were
only fans who came up to me at a recent
match calling for a people's vote I
think this idea I think there are remain
as you say saying get on with it
I think there are an awful lot of levers
who are actually saying this is not the
bracelet we voted for I don't see how if
you vote if you're a Tory MP like the
minister miss mr. Braverman who were
just heard just now if you're a Tory MP
who really believes in BRICS it you
can't vote for checkers you can't vote
for this plan that Theresa May is doing
because it's it's not bricks it I cut I
couldn't support it I mean work because
I think it's going to damage the future
of the country the problems you've got
is if you are going to have any
realistic chance of a second referendum
really mm-hmm
you need Jeremy Corbyn onside where was
he yesterday he was apparently at some
event to do with Pinochet I don't know
but I mean I look you're absolutely
right but look what happened at the
Labor Party conference but Jeremy Corey
made no indication is going to support a
second referendum thus far you see this
is there something else that somebody
said there's a Tory MP amongst the many
horrible things that are being said
about her by her colleagues in the press
somebody quoted Michel Barnier
and this I'm sure will rile the brick
streamis but Michel Barnier apparently
says that the way that he's come across
Tereza mayor's she says no until she
says yes we have the same on the snap
election I think look politicians do
respond to pressure is why the purpose
of yesterday's March it wasn't just have
a mark let's just straight you there
that Jeremy Corbyn is not yes yes of
course it does and it frustrated me
during the campaign do you think it's
because he's a us captain I think partly
is that I think historically he's not
been a big fan of the European Union but
listen the other thing I think that
labour members and Labour MPs need to
understand look at who is pushing
hardest with his brace it now it's the
right wing of the Conservative Party's
resmoke caricature to know is you know
look at the people who will who were the
first in the queue to come on programs
like this to talk about his Rhys mug
Duncan Smith redwood let it's the right
wing let's time they will damage labor
communities more than anything there so
let's talk about the details before what
you want
how many options won't be on the ballot
paper if you did get a second brexit
thing well I don't I don't go for this
idea just in greening flow to this idea
of a three
referendum I don't think that I don't
think that's sensible I think it the the
straightforward answer at this stage I
couldn't say because it depends what's
emerges from this process for example if
what do you want as long as the option
to remain must be on the ballot paper
what the government is saying is it has
to be a choice Parliament this so-called
meaning of although they will only have
a choice between her dealing No Deal
that's wouldn't be an option I think
you've heard deal if her deal gets
defeated mode
no deal may well be an option so I'm
just trying to so it's no deal if she
gets I'm a deal I think I think that
probably is a choice that the country
faces a lot of people will say that
actually no Tereza Mays deal should be
on those but this is what she's trying
to do she's trying to say you've got
people like me over here who are kind of
you know extreme on one side of the
argument even though I think we're
moderate the sensible you've got people
over there the reefs mugs and Ferraris
who want No Deal they were look at this
clean break and she's trying to sort of
project herself as the thing in the
middle
but her plan does not work this is where
these two sides agree but if she gets
the deal through with Brussels you're
saying if that's two futures in
Parliament it shouldn't be on the ballot
paper well I think she can put it to the
ballot paper don't but don't forget it
then still does have to get indoors but
ratified by Parliament and it has to get
ratified by the 27 part other part if
it's baited for in a referendum then
presumably I accept that gives it an
authority but this is the point we are
in a state of chaos and all these other
issues it's a little bit chaotic isn't
it that you're campaigning for if
people's vote and yet you can't agree
what that people's vote that's not in
might that's not in our gift that is not
in our gift because campaign then
showing it I am saying to you I think
there probably there are probably three
options and I'm saying to you that there
has to be one of the options has to be
remain is on the ballot paper and let me
tell you three sure there should be
three options now no I'm not saying I'm
saying there are three possible outcomes
that I see but I can't tell you because
the chaos is such I don't think any of
us can predict what's going down I've
just been talking to some of your guests
downstairs none of us can predict what's
happening I'm simply saying what I think
yesterday showed is the country is not
uniting around any vision of brace it
there is a desire to take a look at this
again and the idea that it's
anti-democratic
the public say whether this is what they
voted for
I think it's profoundly anti-democratic
not to do that particularly given the
mess given the costs given the chaos
given the fact frankly we're becoming a
bit of a joke around the world and given
the fact that government is doing
nothing else meeting none of the
challenges none of the problems that led
to people voting leave in the first
place if if your people's vote campaign
fails and we do leave it in you in March
what happens then
do you campaign to rejoin no I don't
know I really don't know I mean I think
that look if she gets it if she gets a
good deal an MP's vote for that deal
then you just have to say she's got a
Monday for that but there is no good
deal available you know you no longer
hear them saying this is gonna be great
for Britain they just say we have to do
it there's no sort of why but there's no
why at the end of that and I think is
it's always tragic to watch what's going
on I understand why the reason may feel
she has to do this because she became
Prime Minister on the back of this
referendum and because millions of
people voted yes but the idea that
that's the sort of that opinion never
changes that the will of the people is
some sort of static brick that never
ever changes it is changing as I say
people like to project that March estin
is all the kind of usual suspects that
Ramona's I was bumping into people up
and down that March who voted leave I
was bumping into people who didn't vote
in which they had and I think this this
is the other point I think it's worth
making I mean normally two and a half
years you can get a lot done in a
government what if they actually
achieved in two and a half years and two
and a half years during that time one
and a half million young people have
come of age this is about their future
and I think they should have a say as
well okay and just at that point think
we need to clarify we've had a update
from jeremy corbyn's office he was
actually meeting the former President of
Chile yesterday okay okay thank you very
much thank you